dans l'actualité ce soir le chômage à la
baisse le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
a encore diminué au mois d'avril -0 4%
soit 8400 personnes en moins épreuve de
force en perspective sur les 35 heures
le gouvernement propose maintenant aux
entreprises de négocier directement la
durée du travail les syndicats parlent
de provocation une grève aura lieu le 17
juin
après les travailleurs clandestins les
travailleuses sans papiers sortent de
l'ombre femme de ménage garde d'enfants
elles demandent à leur tour des
régularisations sans ce journal en quête
du côté des employeurs un accord mondial
pour bannir les armes à sous-munitions
qui continue à tuer lorsque les guerres
sont finies 111 pays l'ont signé il
manque les états unis la chine et la
russie la france en pleine croissance
démographique elle comptera 70 millions
d'habitants en 2050 c'est ce
qu'indiquent les prévisions de l'insee
premiers bénéficiaires le sud et l'ouest
du pays
enfin le coup d'éclat d'un français à
roland garros jérémy chardy a battu
david nalbandian 7e mondial déception
pour amélie mauresmo sortie sans gloire
par l'espagnol navarro
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous c'est un bon
signal ils montrent que l'économie
française continue à résister à la crise
qu on annonce depuis plusieurs mois le
chômage est toujours orienté à la baisse
même si elle est très légère cette
baisse -0 4% je vous le disais au mois
d'avril
séverine lebrun alexis fisher après un
mois de hausse
la courbe du chômage sans fléchit de
nouveau moins 0,4 pour cent il y a
désormais un million 896 8 600
demandeurs d'emploi pour le mois d'avril
cela fait donc 8400 chômeurs de moins
mais il ya des disparités selon les
catégories
avec un taux en baisse de 0 2%
les seniors s'en sortent mieux que les
jeunes plus 1,3 pour cent ce mois ci sur
un an cependant le chômage des jeunes
est à la baisse et ce sont surtout les
plus diplômés qui s'en sortent
c'est le cas d'emma barcelo ti 22 ans
elle est ingénieur en pétrochimie
elle a à peine fini l'école et pourtant
elle a déjà trouvé un employeur
moi j'ai déjà signé là il ya une semaine
dans une entreprise que j'avais
rencontré il ya quelques mois on a une
j'ai eu une série d'entretiens de
recrutement est donc volé ils m'ont fait
une proposition que j'ai accepté après
un bac + 5
elle va toucher environ 3000 euros par
mois pour son premier contrat et dans
son école la majorité des élèves
diplômés trouveront un boulot en
quelques mois à peine
on est aujourd'hui de nombreux secteurs
en manque de bras
quand on dit quand aux diplômés des
grandes écoles on l'entendait ils sont
très sollicités et les français qui
réussissent à l'étranger sont nombreux
exemples olivier françois
depuis deux ans il est devenu populaire
en italie comme patron de la marque de
voitures lancia à turin philippe
visseyrias karine guillaume un vrai
c'est sa grande fierté son bébé dit il
dans toute sa splendeur c'est la noire
voilà une nouvelle voiture qui doit
signer la renaissance de la marque
lancia ça va coûter entre 20000 et 30000
euros dans le secret d'un cabinet de
design
olivier françois cau vient de les
derniers détails dirigé l'une des
grandes marques de l'industrie italienne
apprendre à fabriquer des voitures un
défi pour cet ancien cadre commercial de
citroën je suis venu beaucoup pour ça
pour faire des voitures les pensées
penser stratégie repenser à la marque et
en dérivés des produits nouveaux donc
effectivement c'est pas seulement la
première voiture de mon père c'est ma
première voiture
après des années de grisaille le soleil
brille à nouveau sur les usines fiat de
mirafiori à turin
c'est là que les lancia sont fabriqués
la réussite d'olivier françois est à
l'image du redressement de tout le
groupe qui a désormais bénéficiaires
pourtant en 2005 lorsque ce français et
recruter plus personne ne croit en
lancia et ses modèles vieillissants
la marque est en train de mourir
on s'est retrouvé au moment de mon
arrivée avec une gamme réduite vraiment
à au minimum la ypsilon la muse a
pratiquement en réalité il n'y avait pas
de nouveau projet un programme est
olivier françois obtient carte blanche
il relooke les modèles convainc carla
bruni de jouer dans ces campagnes de pub
une image qu'il exploite au bon moment
cet hiver alors que toute l'europe
s'intéresse aux amours de la belle
italienne
on voulait un personnage élégant et
votre tempérament
bon ben le fait de s'être marié avec le
président de la république française la
rend pas moins élégante est pas moins
glamour plutôt plus s'ils arrivent à
convenir lancia vers une deuxième vie
j'espère que la vraie marchera mieux là
olivier françois montrera qu'un français
a pu marquer l'histoire de l'industrie
automobile italienne
toujours à propos d'emploi quel avenir
pour les 35 heures le débat n'est pas
nouveau bien sûr mais le dernier texte
de loi du gouvernement pourrait mettre
le feu aux poudres
officiellement la durée légale du
travail est maintenu mais les 35 heures
seraient vidés de leur substance
car le projet veut confier aux
entreprises le soin de négocier au cas
par cas
ce temps de travail les syndicats
parlent de provocation il junca marie
cazaux d'après le projet de loi la durée
légale du travail sera toujours fixée à
35 heures hebdomadaires
mais en cas d'accord dans les
entreprises il sera possible de
travailler 48 heures au maximum
il faut garder une durée légale du
travail c'est leur père on en a besoin
mais il faut aussi qu'on donne davantage
de souplesse dans l'entreprise par la
négociation et par des accords entre
l'employeur et les syndicats de salariés
concrètement les entreprises disposeront
de deux pistes pour allonger le temps de
travail
premièrement augmenter le nombre
d'heures supplémentaires celles ci ne
seront plus plafonné à 220 heures par an
comme aujourd'hui les partenaires
devront déterminer un nouveau volume
d'heures sup
ces heures seront toujours payées 25% de
plus
deuxième piste généralisée
l'annualisation du temps de travail
le forfait de 218 jours par an
accompagnée de rtt sera supprimé les
partenaires devront négocier un nouveau
forfait
mais au delà de 218 jours les jours
travaillés seront payés 10 % de plus
pour valider ces accords la signature
d'un syndicat minoritaire suffirait à
condition qu'ils représentent au moins
30% des salariés et qu'aucun syndicat
majoritaire ne s'y oppose
pour la cgt et la cfdt ce projet de loi
est inacceptable nous ça va au delà du
problème des 35 le prendre secteur reste
formellement mais on dérégule
complètement la législation sur le temps
de travail ce soir toutes les grandes
centrales syndicales sauf la cftc sont
réunis afin d'élaborer une riposte
commune et cette réunion vient de
s'achever bonsoir sophie brune vous êtes
sur place
il y aura bien une grève effectivement
ce sera le 17 juin prochain nouvelle
journée d'action à la fois des
manifestations et puis un appel à des
arrêts de travail
deux syndicats sur les quatre qui ont
participé à la réunion appellent à cette
journée d'action il s'agit de la cgt et
de la cfdt pour l'instant force ouvrière
et la cgt réservent leur réponse il faut
rappeler qu évidemment la cgt et la cfdt
sont les deux organisations qui avait
signé la position commune sur les 35
heures et ces deux organisations
s'estime ce soir trahi par le
gouvernement pour la cfdt
c'est le gouvernement qui décide de
déclencher le conflit donc une nouvelle
journée d'action le 17 juin
à noter que ces deux organisations ont
précisé qu'elles s'engager à ce que
le baccalauréat ne soit pas perturbée
par cette journée d'action c'est la même
semaine en clair elles vont s'assurer
que les transports vont bien roulé ce
jour-là et pourront amener les élèves
jusqu'à leur salle d'examen même le 17
juin donc cette nouvelle journée
d'action sur les retraites mais aussi
sur les 35 heures merci sophy pour ses
toutes dernières précisions
la parité s'applique aussi aux sans
papiers après les travailleurs
clandestins ce sont maintenant les
femmes en situation d'illégalité qui
sortent de l'ombre garde d'enfants femme
de ménage elle travaille parfois depuis
des années vous allez les entendre mais
nous avons voulu aussi aller au delà du
constat ce soir car l' affaire concerne
aussi les employeurs c'est le dossier de
cette édition il est signé jérôme
bernard vincent barral samuel humaine
elle s'appelle maria mme awa omari
certaines travaillent en france depuis
plusieurs années sans papiers voici
mijas ya baptiste elle dit être tombés
dans des escaliers en travaillant
désormais elle est sans revenu
alors depuis vendredi dernier
elle occupe les locaux de la société de
nettoyage qui les emploient qui les
exploitent
distel messieurs qu'ils allaient ils
travaillent ici
il a pâti me retrouver dans mon lieu de
travail m'a dit madame rester en poste
et on a pitié de vous c'est vous vous
arrangez mais maintenant vous n'allez
pas nous fourgue la mer leur objectif
forcer leur employeur à demander leur
régularisation
avec des fiches de paye à l'appui celle
de fanta sidibé par exemple
vous êtes sans aucun doute le patron a
hésité avant de nous rencontrer
il jure qu'il ne connaît pas de fanta
sidibé je peux vous assurer que ce
salarié au nom de sidibé fanta m'a
jamais fait partie de notre personnel
en réalité j'ai travaillé ici sous
d'autres noms avant de travailler à mon
nom ça fait trois ans que je travaille
ici j'ai laissé les impôts cette année
la fiche d'imposition
vous voyez c'est mon nom qui est là et
après comme ça devient plus remplies ça
c'est pas moi qui l'a écrit quand même
la manette et clé là non je pense pas
que ça soit nécessaire en face à notre
insistance il accepte finalement de
consulter ses dossiers
ces phrases et là miracle
sidibé fanta est de retour on a retrouvé
ses papiers des faux évidemment ce
qu'elle a présentée pour être embauchée
pour bah oui mais on l'embauché avec sa
pièce sans titre de séjour regardez bien
la photo sylviane elle là bas
l'employeur plaide la bonne foi mais du
coup il reconnaît maintenant très bien
son employé maintenant oui la rue la
veille encore fanta sidibé travailler
dans cet hôtel alice hervé les petits
déjeuners la directrice ne se doutait de
rien en théorie la loi ne l'obligent pas
à vérifier les papiers de l'employé d'un
sous traitant
je la considère comme un professeur
lemay location de draps de lin moi si
vous voulez une femme de ménage c'est
comme si j'avais une machine à café en
fait que j'emploie c'est parce que
j'utilise tous les jours et puis je fais
ma facture de location à la fin du mois
si vous voulez c'est comme ça n'en
disons pas n'a pas entrer dans les
détails de papier ok ce n'est pas tout à
fait vrai les tribunaux commencent à
poursuivre des entreprises parce que
leurs sous traitants emploient des
clandestins
le mouvement des sans-papiers dans la
restauration leur a donné de l'espoir
leurs arguments sont prêts à ceux qui
disent que vous aviez conscience que
vous êtes en situation illégale et
qu'aujourd'hui vous profité du système
pour effet de régulariser vous retombez
est sans doute ils peuvent le dire mais
euh moi je dirais reconnaît pas en
situation irrégulière pourquoi nous on
contribue en cotisant ont payé leur
cotisation et ses cotisations
où est le bon le moment d'un que c'est
l'argent on nous dit pas que c'est
l'argent d'un sans papier ça ça c'est
dit jamais quand on part dans les salles
des recours on ne demande pas le papier
en france les statistiques sont floues
il y aurait au moins 90 milles
travailleuses sans papiers le conflit
des pêcheurs c'est le statu quo
aujourd'hui à son tour la rochelle a
voté la suspension de la grève mais le
mouvement continue dans la plupart des
ports de bretagne notamment une
manifestation régionale à d'ailleurs
rassemblé vous le voyez plus d'un
millier de marins à quimper quelques
élus participaient également au défilé
ainsi que des commerçants les
agriculteurs eux aussi font pression
trois dépôts de carburant étaient
bloqués aujourd'hui par des exploitants
dont celui ci de chignin en savoie là
encore pour réclamer des rabais sur le
gazole et puis beaucoup d'autres
professions sont concernés on le voit
peu à peu voici l'exemple d'un infirmier
libéral en lozère il fait 250 km par
jour avec sa voiture personnelle
reportage léolin bertrand gille rufino
c'est sa façon à lui de lutter contre la
hausse continue du prix du carburant
christophe rang ne va plus dans les
stations essence
il a sa propre cuse le gazole qui
l'utilisent aujourd'hui il a payé il ya
trois mois le litre était alors 15
centimes d'euros moins cher
qu'aujourd'hui
l'augmentation arrive quand même mais
avec trois mois de décalage
christophe franck est infirmier libéral
en lozère le département le moins peuplé
de france
chaque jour ils parcourent en moyenne
250 km ils consomment dix mille litres
de gazole par an et il est inquiet en
donnant sa facture carburant a doublé
c'est sûr c'est le travail qu'on fait
par plaisir mais il va revenir au moment
où on prend fall plus le faire
uniquement pour le plaisir il faut il
faut quand même arriver à gagner sa vie
et donc pour certaines y est ça va être
ils vont être obligés d'arrêter
rapidement il ya pas des mesures qui
sont prises comme tous les infirmiers
ses frais d'essence sont en partie
remboursé problème l'indemnité n'a pas
varié depuis des années si ça continue à
augmenter je vais on va être obligé de
modifier la façon de travailler et donc
de refuser je pense que déjà ça se fait
dans certaines régions on refuse les
swing trou trop distante du cabinet ça
serait un désespoir
pourquoi parce que je suis chez moi et
je suis bien soigné et tout ce qu'il me
faut autant qu'à l'hôpital
attaché à ses patients isolés dans la
campagne
christophe franck ne souhaite pas
raccourcir sa tournée mais l'idée de
payer cette année plus de 15000 euros en
carburant lui donne parfois envie de
retourner en ville
dernier élément sur le sujet et qui
risque d'envenimer la situation
bruxelles demande officiellement à la
france que les pêcheurs remboursent à
l'état entre 65 et 70 7 millions d'euros
dead et reçus ces derniers mois jusqu'où
il doit aller la justice française dans
la prise en compte des coutumes ou des
croyances c'est la question qui est
posée après une décision rendue à lille
le tribunal a annulé le mariage de deux
époux musulmans car la femme avait menti
sur sa virginité
le juge estime que la confiance du mari
a été abusé arnaud boutet marianne masse
dominique maes ce 8 juillet 2006 dans la
grande salle ils sont tous là les futurs
époux et leurs familles lui ingénieur l
étudiante tous deux de confession
musulmane
le mariage est une fête mais la nuit de
noces tournent au scandale la mariée
n'est pas vierge
elle lui avait juré le contraire des
lendemains le plaignant veut annuler le
mariage et son épouse fini par accepter
deux mois plus tard le tribunal de lille
confirme l'annulation il se fonde sur un
article du code civil
s'il ya eu erreur sur les qualités
essentielles de la personne l'autre
époux peut demander la nullité du
mariage quand le conjoint se trompent
eh bien il peut invoquer son erreur
devant le tribunal exactement comme dans
le domaine contractuel où il viendrait
dire dans un an
un voisin j'ai acheté un tableau en
croyant qu'il était picasso et je
découvre que ce tableau n'est pas de
picasso je demande la nullité de mon
contrat pour erreur la défloration
dissimulé peut-elle devenir cause de
nullité
oui disent les juristes non car c'est
une régression répond l'association ni
[ __ ] ni soumises à moi je suis vénère
j'ai la rage on est des femmes comme les
autres
aujourd'hui la justice reconnaît accorde
le droit que la virginité peut être un
élément essentiel
le tribunal s'est pas fondées sur la
virginité ou la non viabilité
il a simplement soulevé que l'un des
deux époux avaient menti sur un aspect
essentiel aux yeux des deux époux du
couple la jeune femme at-elle subi la
pression des deux familles certes chaque
année plusieurs centaines de mariages
sont annulés mais la cause du mensonge
sur la virginité constitue une première
en bref quelques 300 personnes de la
communauté des gens du voyage ont
participé dans le silence et le
recueillement aux obsèques de l'un des
leurs joseph guerdner 27 ans tué par un
gendarme alors qu'il se trouvait en
garde à vue à draguignan et tentait de
s'évader
c'était à brignoles tout à l'heure pour
ce défilé unis marche s'est ensuite
déroulée à draguignan image signée
sylvain rousseau les intempéries suite
c'est maintenant dans les alpes que les
fortes pluies provoquent des
perturbations les le tunnel du fréjus a
été bloqué par une coulée de boue et
plusieurs villages ont dû être évacués
sur place benoit gadret olivier
jacquelin un torrent d'eau et de boue
d'une puissance rare en temps normal
cette rivière coule paisiblement la crue
est d'autant plus impressionnante que ce
matin une poche d'eau s'est formée dans
la montagne avant de déferler sur le
village
certains rochers sont venus taper contre
le pantone hôtel international et donc
un énorme bruit beaucoup voir en albums
ont dû sortir en courant de l'atelier le
torrent vient raser les fondations des
maisons 90 habitants dû être évacuées en
urgence il faut dresser des murs de
pierres pour contenir la crue un même
phénomène c'est à dire que le terrain
disparaissait sous la maison et la
maison s'écroulait à l'origine de cette
crue la fonte des neiges et les fortes
pluies qui arrosent la maurienne depuis
48 heures
de nombreuses routes sont coupées dans
la vallée une coulée de boue a recouvert
la rampe d'accès du tunnel de fréjus
plus 200 poids lourds sont bloqués en
amont sur une aire de service
problème ces composants retards sur les
livraisons enfin tout pour les clients
sont pas contents le tunnel pourrait
rouvrir dans la nuit mais la situation
reste difficile
de fortes précipitations sont attendues
ce soir oui dans l'isère c'est une mini
tornade qui est passé la nuit dernière
sur saint marcellin plusieurs milliers
d'arbres desnoyers il y en a beaucoup là
bas ont été arrachés ou ont été couchés
par le vent
météo france émet une alerte de
vigilance orange jusqu'à demain 10h
rester prudent de fortes pluies sont
attendues sur la drôme l'isère et la
savoie
image aussi de belgique ou des trombes
d'eau se sont abattues sur la région de
liège les dégâts vous le voyez sont
impressionnants on compte plus les rues
les caves inondées beaucoup d'habitants
sont cloîtrés chez eux par chance il n'y
a pas de victime la situation est la
plus grave qu'ait jamais connu la région
la pluie a cessé heureusement en fin de
matinée enfin en italie dans la région
de turin les crues et les inondations
ont fait deux morts et deux personnes
sont portées disparues le pot déborde
3000 personnes ont été évacuées les
écoles resteront fermées demain à turin
le rapport plutôt inquiétant d'un
laboratoire lyonnais et du fonds mondial
pour la nature sur les pcb on avait
évoqué ici même la contamination de
plusieurs grands fleuves par ces
pyralène et bien l'étude montre que les
consommateurs réguliers de poissons
pêchés dans le rhône présente un taux
moyen de pc des cinq fois supérieur à la
moyenne
agnès monte benoît jourdain sur leur
t-shirt l'heure toute contamination au
pyralène ses soixante volontaires sont
inquiets ils viennent de l'apprendre
tous sont contaminés aux pcb je suis
résigné
pas tellement encore une fois pour moi
mais pour ceux qui vont descendre de nom
de nous est
notre mauvaise façon de gérer des
pollueurs les prélèvements effectués sur
où il ya deux mois l'ont prouvé starz ou
inconnus plus on consomme de poissons
plus en concentrent à son tour des pcd
dans le sens un peu si l'on vit loin
d'un fleuve plus si l'on est riverain
est cinq fois plus que la moyenne si on
mange beaucoup de poissons août dernier
la pêche est interdite sur le rhône trop
pollués par ces pcb des molécules
cancérigènes qui s'accumulent au fond
des cours d'eau un poison échappée de
nos vieux frigos ordinateur ou
transformateurs
depuis des dizaines d'années pourtant
cette étude pilotée par des médecins
indépendants et la première sur la santé
humaine
nous avons un problème aux pcb nous
avons un problème de santé publique aux
pcb
faisant le point mettons le à plat et
ainsi on pourra savoir qui a été
contaminée qui ne l'est pas et qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire mais d'ici quelques
mois des études plus poussées devraient
être menées sous l'égide de l'état
résultats attendus pour 2010 la france
comptera 70 millions d'habitants en 2050
c'est la principale information d'une
étude prospective de l'insee nous sommes
le grand pays le plus dynamique d'europe
en matière de natalité et cela devrait
donc continuer nicolas chateauneuf
valérie lucas c'est un petit garçon qui
a pour prénom maxime et qui est née hier
le même jour que vianney dans la chambre
d'à côté sa maman est lui à 30 ans l'âge
moyen du premier enfant pour les
françaises et celle ci a déjà des
projets nos coeurs sont en bretagne ou
normandie en province donc oui sinon
mari peut être mais tu es en train se
serait un livre et des enfants les
français en font tellement que les
démographes doivent revoir leur copie
si rien ne change la france passera
ainsi de 63 millions d'habitants à 67
ans en 2030 voire 70 en 2050 et les
français vieilliront bien l'espérance de
vie des femmes atteindre à 89 ans et
celle des hommes presque 84 ans 7 ans de
plus qu'aujourd'hui
résultat la part des jeunes dans la
population diminuera alors que celle des
plus de 60 ans explosera à l'horizon
2050 avec à la clé de nouveaux
comportements
on observe encore beaucoup de migration
aux âges de la retraite dans les régions
du sud mais on commence à observer une
intensification des l'immigration
aux âges du premier emploi c'est à dire
les jeunes ménages mais en 2030 toutes
les régions ne seront pas égales le
sud-ouest explosera avec une hausse de
la population languedoc roussillon de
32%
suivent les régions atlantiques l'alsace
le sud-est puis le centre l'île de
france dans la moyenne
normandie et nord stagneront cantal est
il se videra -5 5% pour la
champagne-ardenne des tendances qui se
font déjà sentir à lattes par exemple
près de montpellier
la population est passée de 8 mille à
dix sept mille cinq cents habitants
en 25 ans la ville attire les retraités
mais pas seulement
où on a vraiment plus de la moitié des
personnes qui sont des gens qui sont en
activité qui viennent déplacer leurs
activités qui viennent trouver de
l'emploi ici attiré par la mer le soleil
et les emplois les français sont en tout
cas les européens les plus féconds
l'actualité à l'étranger avec d'abord un
accord mondial pour tenter de bannir les
armes à sous munitions il s'agit de ces
bombes qui se dispersent et qui continue
à tuer lorsque les guerres sont finies
bien longtemps après même 111 pays ont
signé cet accord
seul problème il manque encore entre
autres les états unis la chine la russie
l'inde ou israël dorothée olliéric les
bombes à sous munitions sont
généralement largué par avion
chacune disperse plusieurs centaines de
petites bombes qui vont exploser sur de
vastes surfaces les dégâts bien sûr sont
considérables
111 pays dix jours de négociations
tendues à du bla et au bout du compte a
traité qui interdit l'utilisation la
mise au point et le stockage des bombes
à sous munitions cet accord va changer
des comportements dans les guerres parce
que désormais on dira que les bombes à
sous munitions sont inacceptables le
problème c'est que tous les pays ne sont
pas convaincus et les manifestations à
dublin sont loin d'avoir fait plier les
pays producteurs de ces bombes comme les
états unis la chine la russie
absent de la capitale irlandaise autre
problème ces sous munitions n'explosent
pas toujours à l'impact au sol elles
deviennent un danger pour les
populations civiles
car l'explosion peut se produire bien
longtemps après la fin d'un conflit
touchant le plus souvent les femmes et
les enfants qui ne savait pas qu'il
s'agissait de munitions au liban après
des décennies de guerre on estime à un
million le nombre d'armes à sous
munitions et de mines antipersonnel
encore enfouis dans le sol les casques
bleus français des mines il faudra des
années pour dépolluer la zone la france
l'a d'ores et déjà décidé elle détruira
bientôt ses propres stocks de bombes à
sous munitions
la visite à paris de vladimir poutine la
première en tant que premier ministre au
programme des entretiens avec françois
fillon est ici nicolas sarkozy sujet à
aborder entre autres le prix du pétrole
la russie est devenue l'un des premiers
pays producteurs au monde
ce n'est pas la russie qui fixe les prix
a déclaré celui qui reste le maître du
kremlin
mais le marché image signée annie
triboit une histoire presque miraculeuse
en chine dans la région du sichuan 4,40
villageois coupés du monde par le séisme
ont été retrouvés vivants parmi huit
ouvriers qui travaillaient dans une mine
au moment de la catastrophe
ils ont survécu pendant plus de deux
semaines avec cinq kilos de riz pour
tout le monde et de l'autre lui les
rescapés affaibli mais dont les jours ne
sont pas en danger ont été héliportés
vers un camp de réfugiés retour en
france avec l'éducation c'est dans deux
semaines et demi déjà que commencent les
épreuves du bac
un constat cette année qui se confirme
il n'est pas nouveau la filière
littéraire est de plus en plus désertés
par les élèves au profit notamment du
cursus scientifique à tort ou à raison
le bac s apparaître encore comme la
meilleure voie pour les études et
l'insertion professionnelle certains
enseignants n'hésitent pas à dénoncer
cette préférence en parlant de dictature
des mathématiques à palaiseau en région
parisienne aurélia bros jean francois
monier
c'est une espèce en voie de disparition
les littéraires dans ce lit cette
palaiseau cette classe de terminale une
seule littéraire dit l'élève seulement
ici autour de leur professeur de
philosophie il y à 40 ans un bac sur
deux était littéraire aujourd'hui ils
sont 9 % à passer un bac l contre 26%
pour les s en plus ce qui se retrouve là
ne l'ont pas forcément choisi
sur une classe c'est vrai qu'on peut
dire assez péremptoire mais il ya de
moins en moins de vrais littéraires
entre guillemets c'est à dire des
enfants qui sauf qu'ils sont elles par
goût par curiosité par envie de
découvrir des choses par motivation ils
sont elles par défaut pour beaucoup et
meilleurs ils sont mal à deviner les
meilleurs ou les trouve là en terminale
scientifique
ici ils sont quatorze fois plus nombreux
des élèves attirés par l'image
d'excellence de la filière ne
poursuivront pas des études
scientifiques et pour certains ce bac
c'est même un parcours du combattant est
comme chez elle un premier rêve j'ai
redoublé ma première s le clash en
terminale et c'est un peu galère que
j'avais demandée elle en fin de seconde
et ma prof principal de matt m'a dit que
mon futur c'était mieux si j'allais en
est ce que ça m'ouvre est plus de portes
choisir la voie scientifique pour se
laisser un maximum de portes ouvertes
le prof de maths lui même n'y voit pas
forcément une bonne opération
énormément de section qui sont après le
bac et qui recrutent sur dossiers sont
sélectives donc avoir le bac s avec
18001 sa ferme les portes de toutes ces
sections
moi je dirai au contraire que s pour un
certain nombre de gens savent à fermer
des portes avec 28 % d'élèves en mots en
quinze ans la filière elle serait menacé
d'extinction
derrière ce déclin les inspecteurs
généraux craignent de voir disparaître
un pan essentiel de notre tradition et
de notre culture
liés par exemple aux arts et à la
philosophie rendre ses lettres de
noblesse à la filière littéraire sera
donc un des axes majeurs de la réforme
du lycée
engagé par xavier darcos la santé
lorsqu'on parle des maladies du sommeil
on évoque souvent l'insomnie al'inverse
il faut savoir qu'entre 15 et 30 mille
français sont sujets à la narcolepsie de
quoi s'agit-il d'un besoin subi de
sommeil dans la journée
en clair de somnolence poussé à
l'extrême une journée spéciale aura lieu
samedi sur le sujet reportage aux et
blanc la pierre jean francois monier
mercredi après midi pour maël 13 ans il
est temps de s'y mettre
demain contrôle de maths certes ce n'est
pas sa matière préférée mais de là à
s'endormir
difficile à croire
alors que nous le film on m'a elle
s'endort chez lui c'est une maladie la
narcolepsie mal s'est endormi alors oui
ça arrive souvent
oui bah presque tous les jours presque
tous les jours n'importe où n'importe
quand cela veut dire que ma elle ne vit
plus tout à fait normalement à tout
moment ils risquent de tomber et le
sport est devenu particulièrement
dangereux pour lui dans pas trop
longtemps
d'accord d'accord attention même un
simple tour de vélo est devenu un
problème on essaye de pas y penser trop
trop parce que sinon on lui interdirait
de faire tout et on veut quand même
qu'ils vivent normalement sait déjà
c'est pénalisant pour lui on laisse
partir mais on y pense et on lui dit pas
forcément con
qui est la responsable une substance
situé au niveau de l'hypothalamus
elle s'appelle l'orexine ici en rouge
elles contrôlent les circuits du sommeil
quand l'orexine est déficitaire
le système se détraque schéma elle les
premiers signes se sont manifestés vers
l'âge de 11 ans c'est ici que le
diagnostic a été réalisé à partir des
courbes de son sommeil donc je sois 8h à
10h à 12h et 14h ou à 16h s'endort donc
il peut pas se maintenir
réveillez et c'est à ça que servent
c'était c'est à vérifier que
l'endormissement se produit si ce trait
noir indique du sommeil paradoxal qui ne
devrait pas survenir en milieu de
journée
ni en fin de journée ni même en tout
début de nuit
il ya des matières ou du a un peu fléchi
chez mal comme dans 70% des cas la
maladie se complique
il lui arrive aussi de s'écrouler sous
le coup d'une émotion d'un fou rire par
exemple comme sur cette vidéo filmée par
son père que cheikh mes copains la cour
de récréation
je rigole et puis j'ai les genoux qui
fait chimie la tête qui tombe ça peut
aller jusqu'à tomber par terre se méfier
des sommes de lancer les enfants et ne
pas se moquer des petits flemmard ils
peuvent être touchées par cette maladie
rare que seul un traitement au long
cours peut soulager aller pour se
réveiller en fanfare l'environnement
avec un trésor de la biodiversité perdu
en plein océan indien à 450 km de
madagascar il s'agit d'un endroit
paradisiaque et protéger des touristes
seuls quelques rares scientifiques
connaissent l'existence de ce site
classé patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
une exposition à la ménagerie du jardin
des plantes à paris nous fait découvrir
cet atoll agnès monteux eric de lannion
c'est un sanctuaire naturel intacte
paradisiaque perdu au milieu des
seychelles et de l'océan indien
l'atoll est quasiment inaccessible
ceinture et de coraux tranchant et pas
d'eau potable coeur de ses mangroves
invivable pour l'homme alors sur aldabra
la nature est restée maîtresse
c'est ce qui frappe les rares
scientifiques qui ont eu accès il n'y a
pas de pontault donc on arrive dans dans
l'eau et dans l'eau y est les requins
ont déjà ça commence bien parce qu'on
n'a pas vraiment l'habitude généralement
quand on descend d'un bateau de se
retrouver avec des requins qui
il vous passe entre les jambes et qui se
foutent totalement vous soyez là où vous
soyez pas là on arrive sur la plage via
les tortues qui s'en aperçut bas quand
on la voit deux qui arrivèrent vous vous
poussez flux de 100000 géante de 300 kg
ici il y en a dix fois plus que sur les
îles galapagos les deux derniers
sanctuaires de ses contemporaines des
dinosaures exterminer partout ailleurs
de la réunion à madagascar
les premiers navigateurs comme il colons
en vue le potentiel de garde marges et
que représentait cette fortune pourrait
les laisser sur un bateau elle ne
s'amuse pas et pour les garder pendant
des mois comme une réserve de nourriture
quelques-unes vite au jardin des plantes
parfois depuis plus de 100 ans
les vedettes d'une exposition pour faire
découvrir cette île merveilleuse encore
inconnu du grand public des trésors et
de l'est grâce à quatre expéditions de
dix photographes pour immortaliser ces
espèces parfois uniques comme le rad cet
oiseau qui ne vole plus une richesse
aujourd'hui menacée par le réchauffement
climatique
ada bras menacé par des eaux qui monte
aldabra peu menacé et a été touché par
le blanchissement des corails gardés
jalousement secrets cet atoll sort
aujourd'hui de l'anonymat pour mieux
financer sa protection et les recherches
scientifiques
mais attention pas question pour les
touristes d'y débarquer cabinet ce joyau
le tennis avec l'occasion de pousser un
cocorico après le coup d'éclat d'un
français à roland garros jérémy chardy
145e mondial a battu david nalbandian
tête de série numéro 7 déception en
revanche pour amélie mauresmo qui est
passé complètement à côté de son match
nathanaël de rincquesen chloé cormery il
aurait gagné roland garros
n'y aurait pas fait plus plaisir jérémy
chardy modeste le 145e joueur mondial
s'est offert le maillot jaune de
l'argentin nalbandian tête de série
numéro 6 du tournoi menait malmenés
pendant plus de 2,7
chardy s'est subitement mis à lâcher des
coups comme celui ci commence alors un
improbable renversement de situation
le français réussit à peu près tout ce
qu'il tente
après trois heures et 3 minutes d'effort
chardy atteint le troisième tour d'un
tournoi du grand chelem pour la première
fois de sa carrière
des larmes
amélie mauresmo on a sans doute essuyé
quelques unes avec son entraîneur dans
les couloirs du vestiaire la française
dissimule mal sa déception
aujourd'hui elle a raté son match face à
l'espagnole carla suarez 132e joueuse
mondiale issue des qualifications deux
petits sets au 2e tour
enseignante et c'est pas très plaisant
aujourd'hui josiah face à rafael nadal
nicolas devilder le jeune français a
joué crânement sa chance
soutenu par le public aidé par le filet
il s'incline 6-4 6-0 6-1 les garde fous
rires et victor aussi de roger federer
et puis à l'instant fabrice santoro
vient d'être éliminé un autre genre de
compétition maintenant pas de balles de
tennis mais des mots il s'agit de slam
la poésie déclamée en public
le tournoi réunit une centaine de
slameurs en seine saint denis ils ont
trois minutes pour convaincre
abdelah mostefa david dame aidé à un
brin de poésie pour égayer un canal de
l'ourcq qui en a bien besoin
divers qui ont fait du chemin de filets
états unis l'afrique du sud ou la
finlande
pas franchement la croisière s'amuse
mais une péniche bourré de talent en
route pour la deuxième coupe du monde de
slam devenir des épinards la france du
slam c'est que ces trois minutes maximum
par poèmes qui a pas de musique derrière
pas de costumes mise en scène et que
c'est des poètes qui sont en accord avec
les publics qui sont sectionnés pas de
pluie donc c'est des prêtres qui savent
toucher le public et qu' ils ont préparé
des trucs de trois minutes qui sont des
petits joyaux
c'est le pays où les dieux et les
déesses viennent trouver le repos pays
où la vie est ce veut demeurer pro pays
bourré des richesses mais plein de
grumeaux et voilà donc par exemple en
moins de trois minutes le regard d'un
étudiant de 20 ans sur son propre pays
le gabon à la scène slam en plein
devenir
les groupes s'entraider naître au gabon
comme si c'étaient les équipes des slams
neige comme s'il était d'aider et c'est
pas des déclins du maïs joie je crois
que ça de l'avenir
mélange d'écriture et de performances
scéniques avec ses juges choisis parmi
le public
le slam continue de faire des adeptes à
travers la planète à la grande joie de
son inventeur venu spécialement de
chicago il y à 25 ans la poésie était
vraiment ennuyeuse et je me disais mais
où est passée la passion en fait le truc
c'est que personne n'essayait faire le
spectacle
ce soir là big jim le gabonais a terminé
premier mais le grand vainqueur comme
toujours au slam
c'était dame poésie avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres le chômage à la baisse
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi diminué
légèrement diminué au mois d'avril - 0 4
% au 8400 personnes en moins c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo laurent
romejko point route valérie maurice
20h50 envoyé spécial avec guilaine chenu
et françoise joly et au sommaire
notamment que sont devenus les champions
du monde de football de 1998 très bonne
soirée à tous
info continue et aussi sur france 2
point fr votre soirée sur fond